[Music]
i'm really looking for advice on
how i can
my husband and i can best help our son
recently been convicted
of a federal crime it's dealing with
online
child pornography
[Music]
what's up this is john with the dr john
dolone show
the greatest show ever
ever
except for kelly's murder podcast
which
i'm just gonna leave it at that i think
you want to be in one of those one day
no
i mean it's looking pretty promising
that somehow you and i will both appear
in one
yeah but i don't want to be on the end
of that one
at all i yeah i yes i do not
but anyway
you listen
anyway hey so i'm back uh my wife and i
celebrated 20th anniversary a long time
and we went out uh town for a while it's
my longest time away
and since i started working here
and it was fantastic we missed you you
didn't it was so good
my colleagues are more than enough
sunshine right probably um
man it was fantastic so here's my uh
20-year advice don't wait 20 years to
get away and go have fun and enjoy
yourself here's the other piece of
advice it's the first time ever
um y'all on the show i talk a lot about
don't ever plan to do nothing when you
plan to do nothing you end up this is
what happens you go on vacation you
crash
you drink a lot or a little bit if you
don't drink it all then you eat some big
dumb meal and you stay up real late
watching tv or whatever making out
whatever thing is and then you get up in
the morning and you oversleep you feel
bad the only you can prop yourself back
up is by eating junk food and this whole
cycle starts and then one to two to
three days in you feel grumpy and you're
like
and then i get a weird vacation fight
which is stupid
this time we did none of that in fact we
reversed it
we got up early intentionally
we went on long hikes went to the gym at
the place we were staying which is super
weird right
we took yoga classes in the evening like
whatever was being offered oh long long
rucks i did
i just took some weights with me in the
car
dude it made the trip so great we slept
so deeply we ended up making better
eating choices it was just fantastic and
i will never not do this again um
never go just i'm just gonna do nothing
bro no i didn't get that normal sick
that i get usually when i run real hard
and then i take a week off i get sick
none of that happened it was fantastic
man
so anyway
do more fun stuff before you get old
like me and when you do fun stuff don't
aspire to do nothing just get in there
and get it done be awesome all right
let's go to k in tampa florida what's up
k
um i'm
well
happy belated anniversary thank you
thank you thank you for taking my call
of course of course of course uh how are
we doing
i'm doing okay today um
i've been having good days and bad days
but
um today's an okay day talk to me about
it what's going
on well
i'm really looking for advice on
how i can
my husband and i can best help our son
he is 18 years old so a legal adult
but he's
[Music]
recently been convicted
of a federal crime
and
is facing
prison time um
he has not been sentenced yet
um so we don't know exactly what it's
going to be
um it's dealing with online
child pornography
and
so the attorney
has told us
basically with
this charge
to expect that he would
be sentenced to a minimum of
five years in jail
and obviously then thereafter
[Music]
have a lifetime felony conviction and
have to register as a sex offender
all because
of
something stupid um
which
i told them
i told all my boys when they turned 18 i
can no longer protect you from stupid
yeah um
yeah
well and and i know you know this
um
but
one of the things i think holds back
parents and moments like this
is
um
you really get forced into
pick an aside
and i want you
and your husband as y'all move forward
and we haven't even got to your question
yet but i want you all to move forward i
want you to
work to hold all of this
okay
and what i mean by that is this
there is no innocent player in child
pornography
i i understand that i i know but
i'm not picking at you i just want you
to hold the whole thing okay so i'm not
talking down or anything like that you
just a picture of you and me sitting at
a bar okay or we're sitting grabbing
nachos together
it's i love my son
and i don't want him in jail
and what happened
he can't be around other people and
right so it's all of these things all
and there's kids that were hurt on the
other end of this so it's all that
wrapped up into one big messy
and that's the path forward when we're
grieving this kind of stuff which just
stinks um let but i cut you off tell me
about um tell me how i can help i'm so
sorry about going through this what an
absolute mess across the board
yeah um i mean there's obviously not
much i can do
legally
um
let me let me ask you this this is a
hard question
i put you on the spot what would you do
what would i do
yeah um because it's that it's a balance
between i don't want my kid in jail
i don't want my kid going to prison
and i don't want my kid
trafficking child pornography or holding
child like
hurting children like so what would you
do if you could
um
i guess
you know i
i'd look for alternatives to jail time
whether that's
no access to
anything online and fine with that yeah
um
you know um
he's he's seen a therapist regularly now
if
you know and
he'd be willing to do that you know for
the rest of his life to
have someone to hold him accountable and
that kind of thing but um
you know he he is on the
autism spectrum
he is socially immature
um
and i
think um
he was just
he it was it was his first year at
college he was looking to
meet some people and
ended up in an online chat room and
ended up texting with somebody and a
person
sent him some stuff and
um
you know when that that person was
arrested then they looked at his phone
and
um
because my son had been in receipt of
what that other person had sent him they
came after my son as well
um i don't think he was
looking for
that he was looking for
i don't know
here but here we find here we find
ourselves
um
how can i help you i'm just i'm
heartbroken by this whole mess i'm just
yeah
and i mean i i totally get that there's
a victim in this um
and
um
you know sometimes i feel like my son's
a victim um but i know that there's
you know
every child that's involved in this
they're the victim too
i get that
um
i'm looking for
advice on how to
best support my son
through the sentencing phase through the
incarceration phase
and
hopefully if i'm still alive when it
gets released from prison that um
i can help him beyond and
you know i
i just i don't know how to help him yeah
other than just tell him hey
we love you
um
we'll always love you
and other than that
i don't know what to do i don't know how
to help him
look forward
versus thinking this is
i'm afraid he's going to say this is
the end of my life
and i might as well be dead
afraid he's gonna do something to hurt
himself has he threatened suicide before
um
when he was arrested he
apparently made some comments so they
had some concerns sure
so um
moving forward here's a couple things to
keep in mind okay
um the first thing is this
the sooner
you and your husband transition in your
hearts
from
we can stop this
we're beyond that this is where this is
we're going to make peace with what what
what's moving forward now
and we're not going to make people we
don't have to like it we don't we can
there can be days you wake up and think
i can't believe you're treating my 18
year old baby like this whatever the
thing is
the sooner you make peace with this
train is leaving the station
then you can be about what comes next
but as long as you're trying to drag
that train back into the station it's
going to take off and what it's going to
do is just drag you and your husband
behind you a lot of couples split up
over things like this because we one of
them didn't grieve it one of them
grieved too much the other one thought
and it
it's sitting down and saying this is
happening our son um was involved
whether we think he was involved five
years in jail worth it
he was involved in the worst of the
worst of the worst
and
thank god he got caught early
and
in five years he will
um
what would be 23
he's he'll be still be a young young
young child you know that and then he'll
be out and then we're gonna figure out
what comes next there the word i want
you to keep in your mind is connection
and i don't know what that looks like
for you and your son
that might be a weekly
book study that you all do together for
the next five years
that might be you'll learn something
together like i'll learn spanish if you
learn spanish or whatever that thing is
but he's got to know that he's got two
people that are walking alongside him
even if they're not physically there
that makes sense
yeah
and so we're going to not double down on
what a victim i can't believe this like
nope you broke the law and when this
person texted either you asked for it or
you said sure i'd love to see it or you
didn't go to the authorities when it got
sent to you either way
here we are here we are
and
for a five-year sentence that that tells
me something else is going on either he
asked for it or participated in it or
there was some back-and-forth exchanges
something more than a single text
message one way
for five years
so something else is involved but that's
a that's a whole other call here all
that to say is here's where it is we're
going to do these five years with
dignity and we're going to learn
and we're going to keep our head up and
we're going to
see what does 23 gonna how is 23 going
to be different than 18. and that's the
goal that we're shooting for here
and we're going to have good behavior
and we're going to honor
the young children in our communities
and you and dad are going to have to
grieve this like crazy because y'all had
plans
and you'll had pictures in your head
and you'd already thought about what
graduation would look like
from college and i mean you have those
pictures in your head and you're going
to have to spend some time grieving them
you don't want to have this conversation
at the supermarket hey how's your son
doing
uh they're at church or it's somebody
else's birthday party you don't have
these conversations and here we are
right
there's gonna have to be a dropping your
shoulders and sitting in this for a
minute
and by a minute i mean a season several
months it's gonna hurt and you'll have
to let that process happen
okay
if you don't
it ends up in inflammatory responses it
ends up in rage it ends up in anger it
ends up in blame it ends up in a broken
marriage it ends up in a mess
okay
okay the single greatest book i've ever
read on grief in my opinion
is called finding meaning by david
kessler
i'd recommend you and your
husband read that book
together
and a chunk of that book is about david
kessler's work with parents who've lost
young children they've passed away
in many ways this is a loss for a season
okay
and grieving it in a similar fashion i
think would be really really helpful
okay and then connection connection
connection as hard as that's gonna be
and it's gonna be real hard
yeah okay
um
it may also be worth your soul um the
back end of grief is finding meaning
what are we gonna do in light of
it may be worth
it may be worth down the road
you and your husband finding ways to
volunteer support care for love
trafficked children
children who are sexually abused
children who are going through
deep challenges
as not so much a restitution but a
restoration
how can we be a part of the healing in
our community
that our son helped participate in some
of the hurt
it's similar when a
mother of a son
kills a young family in a drunk driving
accident and he passes away too
mom may get really involved in
alcohol regulations and drinking and
driving and uh she's gonna be about
dad's gonna be about healing the
community from something their kid was a
part of and that may be a conversation
you and your husband have together
what light can we shine in our community
in light of what our sun has done
so we can model here's what this looks
like
here's what service and finding meaning
looks like that's going to be down the
road a bit right now you just need a
season of grief
season of hand-holding you can't get in
front of him and defend him this time
you know that
you can you can hold his hand
and say you gotta go gotta go pay the
piper on this one
but mom still loves you and dad still
loves you and we're gonna be here with
you every step of the way
i'm so sorry kay it's heartbreaking all
around is a big mess for everybody and
um i'm so sorry like going through this
we'll be right back
hey what's up deloney here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at better help betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10
percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com
that's betterhelphelp.com
all right we're back hey before we go on
to the next one we're just talking off
off air about that last call um
a woman called and her son is 18 and
he's been arrested and convicted of
child pornography some shape form or
fashion and in the call uh we talked
about she wanted to know what she could
do while he's in jail
um looks like he's gonna go to jail for
a while um what's the grieving process
look like
and
i wanna make this super clear
often in these conversations if someone
was a counseling client of mine or a
coaching client of mine
there comes a moment when
i will be very very direct
if your child your 18 year old kid your
25 year old kid ends up being a child
molester or trafficking child
pornography
they are a cancer on society and they
need to go away they need to be put
taken out of
communities and put away
they're hurting children affirmatively
hurting children they're participating
in the hurting of children
and
when somebody calls this first time
somebody sits down and has this hard
conversation it says what am i supposed
to do my baby's going to jail
that's
most of the time not the moment to beat
somebody up
and that can happen across the political
spectrum across the trauma spectrum
across the whatever spectrum
talked to mothers and fathers whose sons
you know killed somebody drunk driving
accident and now they're worried like
what are we going to do he's going to
jail and i want to be like he killed a
family right
and there's a hurting mom
and so one of the things i i hope this
show does is help us help everybody
model
when somebody comes to us and they're
hurting i don't care why they're hurting
let's drop our shoulders and let's don't
start with the advice and let's don't
start with the
shaming let's don't start throwing
grenades of well you should have
let's just sit with them and say i'm so
sorry this hurts bad
and you're gonna lose your son for years
because he did some pretty horrible
things and here's what that might look
like and here's a way to keep your
marriage together while that but it's a
it's a sitting down with somebody
and saying let's figure this out let's
go from here
and man that's hard it's hard
but i didn't want people listening to
think i was just blowing off a guy
i've got a little girl i'm pretty i got
a little boy
i'm i have some really strong feelings
about child pornography very very strong
feelings
and also know the voice of a hurting mom
and the world could use a lot more
hey grab a seat let's just sit down for
a second
and a little bit yes a little bit less
yelling and screaming and throwing rocks
at each other
just my opinion there all right let's go
to william in reston virginia what's up
william
hey how are you sir thank you for taking
my call of course man how are you
good
um so what's up so i
i have um
bipolar disorder and panic disorder okay
um and anxiety too um
but i i so i take my medicine regularly
and then i i try really hard not to like
uh
let it affect my life as much as that
possible
um
but over like the last months and a half
maybe two months um i've been having
like nightmares like kind of
consistently a couple times three times
two to three times a week probably where
they
really like uh
affect my sleep and whatnot yeah
so
first of all let me do this
can i stop and celebrate you for a
second
thank you
uh and i and i mean this um
life dealt you a pretty messy set of
cards right
in your seven-hand card you got like
you got like an eight high right you got
like a two and a six and a four and then
an eight right
and
the fact that you've said okay here's my
lot
and i'm gonna play
you've got resilience and character that
is absent from our culture largely and i
want you to hear me say directly i'm
proud of you man oh thank you i really
appreciate that um
getting up every day even when you're
feeling really good and still taking
your meds is hard it's hard and if you
haven't been there you don't know it's
hard
and
riding that roller coaster through a
panic attack is hard
and that low level burn of anxiety all
day every day is hard and you keep
getting up and you keep doing it do you
exercise too
uh yeah i go to the gym
like six times a week
dude see i'm telling you right now man
very few heroes wear capes and you're
one of them
thank you so much hey i'm i'm not
playing am i blowing smoke at you i'm
telling the truth on this show i'm proud
of you man what you're doing is hard and
it's it's really good work and it's
going to pay off generationally for the
people around you so good for you
um
so
you know this but just for the listener
um panic disorder is a common um
comorbidity with bipolar it's just it's
they go together often um does your does
your panic disorders your anxiety does
it run
um only when you are
are running manic or is it kind of run
uh is it trying to align through the ups
and the downs
um
mainly mainly the well it kind of
depends mainly of the of the ups or like
just kind of general i usually have like
a little bit of anxiety every day and
then like the panic attacks come when i
like
get really obsessed about something that
i may have forgotten or not done or
messed up or gotcha
um so your panic attacks have a trigger
so they're almost more anxiety attacks
than panic attacks huh
yeah the ones that are bad like if i
need to go to the er to get because i
don't like to have strong medicine so uh
you know
for addiction reasons so
if i need to i go to the er and i just
pay the bill i don't mind yeah well man
geez it sounds like you have a system
down which is phenomenal i'm proud of
you dude
um and then ah here come the nightmares
right
the worst yeah and okay so how long has
this been going on a couple of months
yeah well yeah i mean i've always kind
of had them but they were really
inconsistent but but the last like two
months ish
it's been more like two to three times a
week i would have
nightmares and what i've tried to do is
limit
i've almost cut tv completely out
because i thought maybe that was it
um
and that did help like lessen the like
severity of them but
uh
but yeah like kind of consistent okay
and have so a couple of times a week for
a couple of months
tells me you're getting close to the
point if you're not there already
where you start being nervous about
going to sleep
correct and then that screws up your
sleep which then
really makes the bipolar management and
especially the anxiety management more
of a challenge throughout the day and
now this it feels like that system
starts spinning faster and a little bit
faster that makes you know what i'm
talking about
yeah that's exactly what happens i'm a
little nervous to go to sleep and uh so
i have a an app thing that i listen to
before i go to bed try to help it but um
okay i mean the sleep is still decent
though because my bipolar meds kind of
knock me out okay
um
so the like the number of hours like is
is it still pretty consistent but the
type of sleep has been not yeah you're
not getting that good deep sleep and
good rem sleep yeah okay
all right so
there's several things um some
psychiatric medications can cause
nightmares or can toggle the sleep a
little bit and
there's so many different things when it
comes to dreams and nightmares in the
psychological literature but the one
thing that's compelling to me is that
nightmares fall in a particular band of
sleep so if you look at sleep like
like um you know eg bdf like notes on a
on a staff like you're playing guitar it
falls in like a band right and so we get
stuck in this layer here of sleep we
can't we're not up or down it's that
part where you have these thoughts and
your brain's still a little bit on but
your body has been uh it's honestly it's
paralyzed but basically your muscles
go into uh there's a word for it it's
not coming to my mind but basically your
muscles quit working for a while right
and it's when you when your muscles are
are still working and you're dreaming
it's when you sleepwalk right that's
right so our body paralyzes itself
basically it's not the right word um but
it shuts down and you get caught in that
in that trap here so some of that could
be medic medication related but i want
you to try something else okay okay
it's called irt
and it's imagery rehearsal therapy okay
and this is for anybody dealing with
dreams there is a correlation there's
some studies that talk about bipolar
disorder and dreams and bipolar disorder
and nightmares um i do not know of any
literature that says here's how you deal
with the nightmares outside of
different medications and
yeah so
um and i'm
i'm always reluctant to do the black
hole the unconscious sleep um i was
pretty convicted
by matt walker dr walker about the
difference between being unconscious and
being asleep right so i think you're
wise at the same time you got to take
your magic i take your meds so all right
here's what imagery rehearsal therapy is
all right
the goal is to change the narrative of
the story
and this sounds bananas
but the research says it's pretty
effective now i haven't seen it
effective for bipolar disorder so you're
going to be the n equals one experiment
okay
okay so here's all it means
you take
one or two or three of your recurring
nightmares the ones that are showing up
in some sort of regularity or the type
right so give me an example of a
nightmare that's showing up more than
once
uh like like demons like not attacking
me but like my house okay
um that's
and then my family's inside with me as
well uh so that's pretty regular tell me
about it
um
just uh like i'll wake up and they're
they're like attacking the house and
then i have to try to figure out a way
to get my wife and my son to safety
okay um
yeah that's pretty regular um i did have
a couple night terrors here and there
where like you wake up and like you
can't move yeah those aren't very common
okay and that's that's what we're
talking about your body's is stuck in
between those two states right
all right so here's what we're going to
do
we're going to write down
that nightmare
and we're going to be very very specific
and we're going to change the ending
we're going to focus on the ending of
that nightmare and we're going to make
the ending wonderful and we're going or
conclude with a neutral ending
where they get inside and then they just
take some diet cokes out of your fridge
and then they leave
or they come inside and repaint the
house for you and turns out they weren't
demons after all they were the neighbors
trying to show you how much they loved
you and appreciate beating it right so
we're going to change the ending of this
in in your awake state
and we're going to write it down and
this is going to dude i know how bonkers
this sounds okay i i know
we're going to write them down and we're
going to rehearse them
probably don't rehearse them on your
front lawn or people will call somebody
on you right
um but we're going to write them down
and we're going to rehearse them and
over time i want you to keep a dream
journal so what we would do is we would
say all right i'm laying down to go to
sleep all sudden my eyes are open
it's i look at the clock it's 12 14 a.m
so we're gonna be that specific i hear
the air conditioner humming my wife is
asleep
and i see the shadow
and then i see the other shadow and then
i hear them clanking around on the roof
right you hear what i'm saying we're
gonna be that specific
and then you're going to open the window
and let them in
and it turns out they're really great
they're just trying to get your
attention because you're gas meters
right you see what i'm saying so what
we're doing is we're teaching our minds
and our bodies we're going to reclaim
these stories that they're cycling
through
okay
that's awesome
we're gonna rehearse it and then i want
you to do is i want you to keep a blank
dream journal by your bed
okay okay
um and the only way you can change
something is by um
uh measure it okay
and so
i don't want you to wake up in four
months and be like oh man these dreams
and you really haven't had one for two
months or you haven't had one for 45
days and so uh i want you to trap when
you wake up you're like whoa
write it down okay and here's what we're
doing okay the word i want you to have
in your head ownership
i am not going to be subjected to these
nightmares anymore i want to begin to
take ownership of my thoughts i want to
take ownership of my body in the daytime
and let that move through the evening
time
okay yes definitely that's what i want
and here's one other thing
i do love love love this is the nerd
part in me talking about
dreams walk me through that one you just
mentioned real quick
so there's demons coming over the house
what does it look like what does it feel
like and don't put yourself into a panic
attack okay so stop before you get there
um but okay talk to me about it
uh usually uh so we live in a town house
uh so it's like a two-story
situation you know and upstairs
downstairs so we we live upstairs and
then downstairs the living room all that
good stuff um but it's all finched in
and everything with our neighbor um
so usually it's like at night when they
come and usually like for some reason
the trees are on fire we do have quite a
few trees in our
um
little complex thing and they kind of
just like
like literally like uh like almost like
a medieval siege
like type of maneuver
um where they kind of surround the house
and then like just start taking down the
fences which would be like the door or
the windows to my son's room which are
on the second floor
and then once they get in the house
usually when i panic and i wake up okay
um
can i tell you something
yes
your kids are lucky to have you
and
you probably beat yourself up over the
bipolar and some of the choices you've
made while having a low season or an up
season over the years is that true
uh yes very true
um
your wife's lucky to have you she's
married to a hero
and at some point sometimes our brains
will recreate stories
that either reinforce how weak we are
or give us an opportunity to do
something
in our dream state that we can't we
don't believe we can do in in real life
and
so hear me say your kids are lucky to
have you
and your wife's lucky to have you and
you're lucky to have them
do you live in a safe neighborhood
oh very safe yes yeah all right so
they don't need a new kind of hero they
got one
they got one in you
and if you every day that you take your
meds and every day you get home from the
gym
i want you to think damn right
with that with that
smile on your face they got me
yeah
you know what i mean
yeah i do yeah it's
yeah
yeah it's hard to like think about
things that i used to do like but before
and now like i just
um
i i really want to show like myself and
my family that like this is a not okay
but it's
we i can manage this and i can do what i
want to do in life just despite
uh you know a couple you know once or
twice a month i might need to call out
because i gotta go home from panics but
other than that
about bipolar is it always feels like so
i'm going to connect your dreams to the
real world that you're being hounded
they're coming for you and any mess up
they're coming for and they're going to
get inside
and i want you to flip that
over now you're in the driver's seat you
know the path forward you just got to
get up and do it anyway
and so those that's true those shadows
that have been haunting you for so long
the only person who doesn't see the
difference now is you
let the shadows go man they can't get
you anymore
yeah you're right you've created a new
path for yourself forward
so one thing that is important i think
is to always ask yourself it doesn't
there's not a lot of scientific
literature here but it's more counselor
stuff
but i always want to ask myself what's
my dream trying to tell me
okay what's trying to tell me
your kids don't need a different kind of
savior and the shadows aren't coming for
you anymore because you got a plan
you're just gonna execute the plan
right
yeah exactly i'm really really proud of
you and you know this i've got to say it
anyway
protect your sleep with all your might
okay so if this doesn't work in a couple
of weeks
um or your panic attacks increase please
go see your doctor okay and let's let
them know about the uh um
about the increasing frequency of your
nightmares we can go from there is that
cool
yeah definitely dude hey will you reach
back out and let us know if this works
yes i will
hey if it doesn't work blame kelly this
whole thing was her idea uh
it wasn't at all it'll it'll all be on
me um but let me know and uh i'll be the
first i'll let everybody know if you
call me back like dude i've tried this
for two weeks this is the stupidest idea
ever my kids saw me rehearsing a dream
in my
mirror in the bathroom and that was
weird and then it didn't work um give
that a shot
um
and let me know how it goes man i'm
so proud every time i talk to somebody
who's wrestling with bipolar and they
got a plan and they've got a management
strategy and they've got a team around
them
it just brings so much of joy to my to
my life because
it's a microcosm of everybody
everybody's got hard stuff bipolar is
really hard
got hard stuff you got to get up and you
got to do it anyway i'm proud of you
brother william i'm so proud of you man
and your kids and your wife everybody
has their hero man way to go we'll be
right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan two hundred trust me that's triple
eight loan two hundred
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
one five nine one in the mls consumer
access dot org equal housing lender 1749
mallory lane sweet 100 brentwood
tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and are not available in
all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to john in
new orleans what's up brother john
hey dr john how you doing today i'm all
right my brother how are you um i'm
redefining the word good
honored equity uh i can already tell i'm
sorry man tell me about it what's going
on
um
38 days ago my daughter
had some blood in her stool
and next thing we knew it was shiva
toxin e coli
which produced into hus causing her
kidneys to fail they had to uh
life flighter from the hospital we were
at to a much uh bigger hospital here in
new orleans and then
uh the next morning she coded for two
and a half hours um
it's probably the most terrifying and
amazing thing i've ever seen yeah
for two and a half hours as they did
chest compressions and then they put her
on ecmo
and she was on ecmo for eight days on
event for another
um 15
well she was on event for a total of 15
days
and
we were told that
there was a two percent chance of her
kidneys redundant function and
we had some pretty horrible
conversations with some doctors and
we've had some uh we made some pretty
horrible decisions that parents should
never have to make
and before we made probably the worst
decision a parent could make we asked
about transferring to another hospital
and we did that and everything changed
i mean
everything
the next morning they were going to
start the dialysis again and
we saw a blue line on her diaper and
she
she's her kidneys the kidney doctor told
us uh two days ago that it's a 90
recovery of her kidneys
but the bigger thing is is that during
that two and a half hours of cpr
she suffered global
brain damage to the deep brain tissue
yep
and
her left side has been mostly paralyzed
but
um doctors told us that she would
probably never be able to do much of
anything and
i'm telling you when i originally
emailed the show to it today it's so
different but
she's she's smiling she's she's laughing
she's she's
trying to clap her hands it's it's so
amazing to see how resilient this little
baby is
um
but
i mean we're
we don't know what the end is going to
look like yeah
so first and foremost dude
like fast if we were just hanging out
i'll give you a hug
and i'd probably hold it a little too
long
okay
i'm sorry man
um
gosh there's so much here
i guess the the first thing is y'all
y'all got a rare opportunity to rappel
down into the bowels of hell
and
have to ask questions and have
conversations that no parent ever ever
ever should have to have
it horrible
and
to resolve to make decisions that no
parent should have to have and then find
out that had you made that decision it
might not have been the right way you
don't mean nick you've been
in heavy trauma right
absolutely yes
um hey uh do me a favor talk directly
into the phone for me
oh there we go um
and then you've got the illness does
everybody blaming everybody for this
parents beat themselves up horrifically
over things like this
yeah that was um
yeah it's
how how can we cope with the guilt of
not
not protecting her better like you know
like that's our job
um so yeah dealing with that has been
been rough yeah
i think the
protection is something we strive for
but in many ways it's an illusion
true and you got to see
i mean you just got your bubble burst on
that illusion sooner than most right
um in a much more horrific way than most
right usually people find that out when
their kids are in a car wreck or they
break an arm or they you know get
coveted or something and yours
end up with
jeez
hut i mean she's louise man what a mess
kidney failure
um
i think that ultimately you got to sit
down and grieve this whole thing start
to finish and y'all aren't there yet
and so the pressure you putting on
yourself right now to solve this what do
we do now
i'm gonna tell you what you do right now
as you get to tomorrow
and then you get to the next day and
then you get to the next day you're in
mile
14 of a marathon
and you're trying to figure out how you
can best massage your calves
and best fix your hurting hip you gotta
finish the race and y'all still got a
ways to go does that make sense
yes
i would love to see
y'all take care of your basic needs
eating
and sleeping
and being with other people do you have
other kids
yeah we've got a we've got a five girl's
daughter geez louise
um
so those conversations are tough too
right
correct yeah that was um you know we
were i originally it was like how do i
explain to my five-year-old that her
sister isn't coming home but now it's
how do i explain to my five-year-old
that when her sister does come home that
she's not going to be the same
in very clear simple terms
kids won't have the same baggage that
you and i will have
and they will be very more
very much more understanding
so it's as simple as
little sis got very very sick and so
she's not gonna be able to move her left
leg and her left foot very well
and then a natural question for a
six-year-old or a five-year-old is well
am i gonna get that sick and you say no
probably not it's very very very rare it
almost never happens but little sis got
it
and so we're going to have to help out
and you are going to get to really help
your baby sister
and using words like her baby and her
baby sister will give her some autonomy
and some ownership
and that helps quell that in that
anxiety
and that little girl is going to absorb
mom and dad's grief and sadness and
that's okay
what's
really important though is that y'all
communicate with her we're very sad
about little sister
not like no it's all good we're just
plugging along and fake smiling in front
of your six-year-old or five-year-old
because she's gonna absorb the tension
and she's gonna think it's her fault
and she's gonna absorb the gap between
what she feels and what y'all are saying
and what she's seeing with her sister
and so it's just being really honest and
saying words like i'm really sad
i'm really sad that baby got really sick
daddy's really sad that um he wanted to
protect his little girl and she got sick
from a little tiny old bug that i
couldn't protect him from
and
i'm very very sad that she got so sick
it's being that kind of honest and that
that language that she can understand
not overthinking it
and also not belaboring it all the time
too does that make sense
yes
yes um
what i'd really love y'all to see is
y'all get home
and get settled at home and sleep in
your own bed together as as all four of
you
and then as the reality of this begins
to set in because right now you're still
running on fumes and you're still
running on adrenaline and cortisol and
you get home and are able to exhale
that's when the deep grief of this thing
will go
okay
number two we haven't been home and
since the whole thing started that's
right and so you haven't slept your
mind's not clear you're probably not
eating very well
um do you have people coming to the
hospital to be with you guys
yeah we've got a very good support
system okay it would be a gift to you
and to them to give them some very
detailed jobs
i need someone to go mow my yard i need
someone to go vacuum my house and wipe
down the kitchen cabinets
i need someone to bring us food and
vegetables and fruits we don't do
mcdonald's again right so very specific
jobs and you've got a team of people
around you who are dying for something
to do to be a part of this and help
and you're gonna have to say here's what
i need and let them go chase that down
is that cool
yeah we
we've been doing that we've got a really
good like i said really good support
system great and yeah we're eating too
much i'm eating too much
probably not eating enough dude i would
be
yeah i don't even want it yeah i would
not be
taking care of myself very well
um but it comes a moment when
taking care of yourself well um i'm
gonna ask you a really hard question
okay um
and so no i'm gonna ask you a hard
question and no it's not a kind question
but i want to be real direct with you
okay
did you intentionally feed your little
girl something infected with e coli with
the intention of making her sick
absolutely not then this is not your
fault
okay
you hear me
yeah it's not your fault
and i'll go further to say
any meditation on this is our fault this
is us we should have we we should have
is a choice to take
it's a it's a false control over
something that's already happened with a
period at the end
okay
so the greatest gift you can give
yourself your wife your marriage your
kid and say the same goes for your your
wife too
is to live as much as possible in the
right now
and one thing that the doctors seem to
have proven to you over and over again
is their predictions are terrible
all right
yeah
she's defied the odds both for the good
and the bad there you go
and my gut tells me is she'll continue
to
that's that's what we're hoping for the
therapies that are available to young
children again i'm not in the business
of false hope the number of parents i've
had to tell them that i've i've been the
guy that comes and sits in that little
square room with you and your wife and
says your baby's not gonna make it okay
so i'm not in the business of giving
false hope
um my oldest best friend on the planet
is a traumatic brain survivor and the
change in technology and therapies that
they have been able to come up with over
the last 20 years is astounding
and i tell you that to tell you
i think you've got every reason to walk
out of that hospital with your head held
high
okay
and quite frankly the other alternative
is to walk out with your head held low
and that's not going to get anybody
anything
do be heartbroken and it'd be really sad
right
yeah and dude you're gonna keep doing it
for a while and there's gonna come a
moment when she's four
and
she's either running around the
neighborhood and you're going to be
grieving over what almost was or you'll
be pushing her and
some futuristic looking wheelchair while
y'all are out at the zoo and it will
just overcome you with like a wave
that how unfair it is that she's not
running around the other kids and it
will be what it is and let that thing
come and feel it and own it
and then
bend down and give that girl a kiss
right on her big sweaty forehead and say
let's go see the lions
right
yes
but
you are in the middle of this and this
is not that moment
this is the moment to be with your wife
to be with your baby little girl to be
with your five-year-old
and they keep telling the doctors not in
this house
right
yeah i'm
i'm glad we
didn't make
make the decision that everyone was
telling us we needed to make yes be at
peace with that
yeah
and
and
forgive yourself for even contemplating
it okay
okay
you gotta stop hanging on to it man
yeah
yeah
you had to dance with the devil and then
you backed out it's good
good for you what made y'all change
hospitals
um
honestly it was the dialysis um she was
going from acute to chronic
and the hospital we were at did not do
chronic dialysis
so we had to go to the children's
hospital that that does the chronic
dialysis
so that that was the driving force of
the move
wow that's fantastic man and then just
so when she your child moved over they
just their care was just different and
better and she got
she perked up
um
something happened in the ambulance on
the way between the two hospitals
she she fell asleep for the first time
in days
she didn't she pretty much didn't wake
up for about 36 hours
and
that was you know
that was when everything started to
change wow i mean everything it was
they were legitimately there to hook the
dialysis machine up
and we were repositioning her when we
noticed the blue line on our diapers so
that they could get access to the
catheter ports yeah
dude that's amazing
and
each day has gotten better each day
we're getting a little bit more of her
back
but there's still a lot of her
a lot of remission of course and there
and honestly there might be
there might be
and that's not for today
is that fair
yes
do keep this uh i want you to get away
from the hospital if you can in the next
day or two
get out to some sunshine and i want you
to go pick up a journal
at a barnes noble or someplace
and i want you to begin writing it down
all of it
what you feel what you think what you're
upset about what you're mad about what
you're scared about
and the goal is when she turns 18 you're
gonna hand this over to her
[Music]
and you're gonna say this is the journey
we took with you
[Music]
this is how much we loved you this is
how long we've loved you
this is a shadow of how much we're gonna
continue to love you moving forward
but write all that stuff down
for you for your wife for your little
one
your five-year-old for everybody
i'm grateful for you man and my heart is
broken for you
i wish i had something that i could stop
my fingers i can't um i can just tell
you as it does another dad i love you
and i'm so sorry
so so sorry man we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow
i'm so grateful and one of the things
i've been most excited about hearing is
that this book is not just for people
who are healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
all right we're back and look at this
it's ben's favorite band ever panic at
the disco with an exclamation point in
it cause why not
you know your band is probably not that
great when you put punctuation in it but
that's just me song is called high hopes
and it goes like this
had to have high high hopes for a living
shooting for the stars when i couldn't
make a killing didn't have a dime but i
always had a vision always had high high
hopes
kelly's always getting high high i had
to have high high hopes for a living
didn't know how but i always had a
feeling i was gonna be that one in a
million
always had high high hopes i'm not one
in a million
this show is though and you are too
we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode my
daughter carries
my ex-wife's maiden name and i took her
to the doctor and they kept calling her
her last name out and they said her her
maiden name in front of her she didn't
understand she'd never heard that name
before she's you know she's four and a
half years old now but i believe that a
person's name
is a
deeply important
part of a person's psyche
he was in spanish class and they had a
day of the dead project and they had to
make the little ofrenda where they had
to make the memorial really the only
person that he knows that's died was his
dad so he made that and that resurfaced
a bunch of questions we were digging
through photos and he found a photo of
his his dad's biological father and he
said who's that and i was like okay this
is your dad's dad unfortunately he died
when your dad was younger
well how did he die
he committed suicide
so then you have this beautiful
autistic brain sitting there
who looks for patterns in the world
that's right he said well if my dad did
it
and his dad did it does that mean i'm
going to do it
you